[Music]
this Japanese man is facing serious
charges because this whole heap he
bought he reserved and cancelled 1873
stadium seats to watch a baseball game
of his favorite team and right before
the reservation window he cancelled on
all of these he created fake names like
he went above and beyond to do this and
this particular game had high stakes so
it was a pretty expensive Oh a game to
attend and he ended up costing his
favorite team a loss of about a hundred
and five thousand dollars why did it do
the game buy these tickets so the game
could keep going on to sit alone right
but they went they were gonna cancel
this game a because I've co-lead no this
one actually kept maybe this one was
back in September oh so he wanted to go
and sit alone yes he wanted to be alone
I get it on this [ __ ] it's not a bad
idea TV put it in your [ __ ] house
yeah there you go you're alone that's
also weird cheering with people is fun
is that - cuz like okay the part that I
just don't understand is logic it's like
all right you have a favorite team that
you loved so much that you want to go
live to see this game but haven't you
thought about the repercussions for this
team now they have they lost a lot of
money also there's not a lot of fans
that would have been there to support
the team that also gives good morale
like I think he did this so that he
could be in like a BuzzFeed article
where it's like man buys a whole thing
answers at last minute tickets it love
it
is it the one they also sell $12 hotdogs
in Japan I don't know they're pointing
to this like big empty area my goodness
and they were just saying that's unusual
like that's Hawaii you know all these
seats were reserved and up there - yeah
up in the Cobra here that's so funny
no right race that's it like yeah right
that's cool yeah he was here though so
there was like a lot more fan so this is
his favorite team hate him now probably
would it have been okay if he did this
but then didn't refund everything and
like you actually paid for everything
yeah personally for me it's like a half
yeah because the other half is like well
what about the team having people there
to support the team you know like the
whole like energy and i think you're
gonna guy that got away with if he had
just did like the c surround him so if
he had did like the for perimeter seats
around him
yes like he's like in the middle of this
like that would have been cool like that
and if you pay for it wouldn't cost you
that much you would have been out of
like five on the dog
yeah but then when you know you're going
to get a hot dog you got to go around
people you can [ __ ] sprint to the
hotdog stand those are skinny yeah you
know what I can run anyway yes so then
it took a while for them to drag your
ball come and figure out like wait this
is something right and so once the
police or whoever was in charge of this
investigation once they contacted him he
was like yeah it was me like I did it
like Oh didn't even tried tonight thanks
to whip-it here just like yeah I wanted
to be alone and I liked it and I want
you to know I liked it and I'll do it
again if you give me a chance it was
also like he wanted to stand out on TV
yeah the leader is that it created a
huge loss a monetary law was broke
that's what I want to know like I just
met em yeah they're mad right I get why
they're mad yeah so there's this is how
they weren't in it is he's facing
serious charges for allegedly causing
serious financial losses oh so he's
getting sued probably natural losses oh
damn dude just because he wouldn't do a
bit he wanted to he wanted to be alone
and he also wanted to stand out on TV of
course he wanted to stay on TV that's
the whole benefit don't see what he did
that was illegal right and I can see
being frowned upon by having sex on the
plane criminal right if he's getting
sued for a loss yeah yeah but I don't
know I wonder how that would hold up in
court because since he didn't do
something this is one of those things
where like the law probably hasn't
caught up with it yet yeah so they're
just gonna figure out like the right
legal regulations case that like in the
future they're gonna refer back to this
case well you could say financial
damages and probably pay you the
suffering there you go ten point eighty
six million yen buddies that was even
more than a hundred and five thousand
dollars no no no yeah it's like now you
should know I literally just say what's
on my mind right now Bobby I know that
well cuz I think yeah it's not like I
don't know anyway yeah the one that I
that I've seen like this guy is is his
name Josh Duhamel oh yeah yeah faster
ones like a I was burnt like a UFC fight
like frenzy so I went to like three or
four of them and at all four of them I
always see him and then just the two
seats next time always empty so I felt
like he always bought all three just so
I can live like cheering room that's the
more cazuca Zuckerberg he bought the
house away yeah he bought the house
around him yeah I bought the houses
around him in there was in Silicon
Valley Wednesday but he bought the
houses on the left and the right to him
because the realist realtor in the
neighborhood were using those as selling
points
stay right next door Mark Zuckerberg so
he like that's smart
now the selling point is you can live
next to the don't live next to the house
that mark owns but then you can't really
[ __ ] about your neighbors that selves
because your Facebook [ __ ] existed
you imagine piss a lot mugs like no you
can't get all whatsapp you can't get on
it sir you can't get on [ __ ] Facebook
yeah before they bought Instagram I was
all like Facebook sucks now they bought
instrument I like Facebook school yeah
what's that literally they bought
whatsapp to like now will you open it
like you know you open on Instagram says
Instagram about Facebook yeah the same
thing with whatsapp do you think that
guy who who's in the social network with
him the like the friend is like not on
any of these platforms because that [ __ ]
Mark Zuckerberg is like [ __ ] boy Justin
Timberlake's camera oh [ __ ] I love man
he probably gave him like he probably
bought MySpace and gave it to him but
like nobody goes to myspace he's just
like yeah almost
he doesn't embrace character doesn't
thrill he have ownership in the to
because I remember they were trying to
realize with a couple years ago yeah
myspace is like your filed away under
history like yeah that's not coming back
but they thought that because of the
name recognition I think yeah yeah
spikes of mine no I Justin Timberlake
played the guy that owned Napster and I
think he started something Sean Parker
what he he started something new that
people are he remember what it is though
well Sean Parker day yeah he started
something new
he did a good couple things my facebook
yes books really if I bought all the pit
tickets at an Eminem concert I was
trying to think of whether I would enjoy
that more because it's like oh I'm the
only one he would hate you or or if like
lock eyes I feel
we'd be less interested in like Eminem
though and more interested about if
anyone's trying to sneak into this pit
that I saw yeah yeah they like get some
cigars to like play all the corners late
no no no no no like what a dog boxes
territory and it's like maybe three
drinks I'll get you drinks that would be
the most ball of [ __ ] I wouldn't do it I
get a conscience of a blob I out like a
small theater like what the Vista
something like that yeah I'll take up
for a movie yeah yeah I'll do that just
go see a real [ __ ] movie or you can see
a movie after it's been out a while
comes in I feel some type of way I want
all of it how about you go see a movie
during Cove in nah they're closing like
that would go in and I would like
literally be watching it in my boxers
you know this is me now you should be
the best place to try and like [ __ ]
around with the chick oh yeah yeah yeah
you took a chick to a Steven Seagal
movie and I was like nobody's here
you lose your virginity to a packed
theater though I did in the packed house
x-men too if any night in your virginity
yeah during the Wolverine [ __ ] this
go I'm not actually there the Wolverine
series [ __ ] [ __ ] me in public whose girl
why did you [ __ ] eat her it was
worried she's sitting in her lap how
does it work yeah she was writing me
reverse our idea was love it was her
she's very assistant wasn't it
that's what private wait that's just
like in public but it's a packed house
believe oh yeah I didn't want to [ __ ]
know x-men - x-men United Jesus did you
you've never [ __ ] in public since then
no well Wow oh but what it's just making
it what exactly for making it work what
did you do
handy I was in I was at a university and
I got I got blown bind an area public
area on the [ __ ] believable but um it
didn't smell bad you won't even let her
blow you anywhere she can blow me so no
no you want me to do anything no that's
not true about the car is not it's kind
of halfway public not really cars come
on come on it's uncomfortable I do a lot
of [ __ ] in my car it's feel like I'm in
high school again
yeah well that ain't for you Nicky like
where you might get caught yeah in
public yeah the car you might get caught
I Drive like a 405 you're high we happen
to drive away road head road head that's
pretty good that's fun no huh it's cuz
the console man the console [ __ ]
everything up for road hassle but also
like trying to time to like focus on the
road in LA and get rolling here just
like yo yeah yeah
what about road head in the back of Ober
yeah there you go let's see that's does
that count as road head cuz usually it's
someone's driving it ought to yeah well
yeah wait for the kavita's end a little
bit a little bit
[Music]
[Music]